so my name is Rafael and I'm from course
I'm going to speak about speaker
identification by the way we're also a
Python shop as well but without the
ready thing which sounds cool
so I'll jump to the video to that
problem that I'm going to describe and
then I'm going to work backwards from
that so what is the speaker
identification if you go to academia you
would find these two disparate
communities that what they're trying to
solve is this we have this list we we
get an input of a recording and we want
output to be a list of ranges where we
say who spoke when so this sounds pretty
simple we have Alice and Bob speaking to
one another and we want to be able to
say that the blue dots are Bob and the
yellow ones are Alice why do you want to
do that because in this case we're if
we're eavesdropping in the middle and we
want to be able to know who said what so
this is two different communities when
you go to speech one of them is called
ionization where people try to identify
all of the ranges so we want to say this
is speaker 1 and this is changing to
speaker 2 and the other community that
does that is called verification where
they care given one of these segments to
say who is the speaker or to say I'm
pretty sure this is Alice so I'm gonna
work backward now and the big question
is why should we do that
so at course AI we help our customers
record their conversations with their
customers speaker separation is pretty
important for that task first of all
when we do that we are going to turn
data into text and separating the people
helps those algorithms perform better
afterwards if you look at the example
here when you get a call and you want to
browse around and see what happened in
the call having the separation
can really help you find the interesting
spots or see if if anything was said by
the person who works for you or by the
person who is your customer finally down
the line we want to identify things such
as long monologues in this code we can
see that Joe spoke for a really long
time
he didn't pause to listen to the
customer and you should probably work on
that to listen to the people that you're
talking to also this is very useful for
predicting whether the customer is going
to buy from you or are they happy with
your representative and this comes in
engagement so when we see these beats
where everybody are talking and they're
talking to one another this is a very
good sign it means that people are
asking questions they are interested in
the conversation they are not just
waiting for it to be over so they can go
to their next meeting so a little bit
deeper into the motivation so
understanding conversation or speech is
useful for many many applications we all
know AI agents such as Alex Google home
Siri if you work in u.s. you might be
transcribing physician notes for
practices in the US or our business is
to guide humans in giving better having
better conversations with the people
that their company works for our medium
is sales conversation this is usually on
conference lines or phones so people
phone in into a WebEx or zoom and have a
conversation with their customers most
cycles according to Salesforce is about
92 percent of sales includes some kind
of phone call or conference call this is
natural speech it has no restriction so
this is not serious not easy like Siri
remind me that XY that so we we don't
know what they're going to say and we
can train them like Siri or Google
trains us to learn what sentences work
and we are looking at sales calls which
sell things which cost thousands of
dollars or more so people care about
these conversations these aren't just
the hot
representatives calling you to bother
you to switch from yes these people
worked hard with their marketing to get
the customer into the into the
conversation and they care about the
output of that conversation because it
costs a lot of money
these are usually 10 to 60 minutes long
and right now in course we have
thousands of users and we record an hour
of audio every 10 seconds as to the
algorithms you know have to be scalable
and before ready recorded over to
millions of these so now we have the
data to do some interesting stuff so
what what are the kind of questions that
our framework can help you with you can
find unsure important moments for
example the customer asking about
security so if you're JP Morgan and you
are talking to a customer and you want
to see where do come security concerns
come up you can use the the topics that
we identify in the text to see where the
prospect talked about security if you
want to coach you representative
effectively you can help them find the
best and answers that people answered
about what's double ventilation you can
we can deliver the call summary and key
points automatically for examples if you
mentioned that you you're on your to-do
list is to send the customer some kind
of material and you'd get an email
reminder about that we can provide live
guidance so if the customer mentioned
security we can pop up this message that
says remind them that we are gdpr
compliant is everyone here gtp are
compliant JP Morgan hope you are
we've 20 days more right so provide
marketing and product with the direct
view of what the customers needs and
wants and wishes so right now this is
one of the biggest value points that
didn't exist before this kind of tools
were around when you are trying to
decide what the company should build in
in the old way the tech works or any
industry you can bring in some few
people and ask them
what do they want you can send out
people with questionnaires and ask them
what do they want but actually all of
the sales conversation that your sales
people are having used to be thrown away
nobody could go over all of these and
see what happens so if I want to see how
many of my customers care about gdpr if
you don't have this kind of technology
you just can't you can listen to five
calls or ten calls or a hundred calls
and say this was mentioned three times
or four times using our software you can
go to all of the sales calls and just
write gdpr and you'd see all of the
cases that it mentioned you can see
whether the sales calls where this is
mentioned you are getting more wins or
not depending on on the answer so this
can really help you shape your product
for the future giving that the real
customer feedback okay so we're done
with the motivations we want to answer
all these really cool questions but I
don't know if you've seen the thread
they're all based on someone saying
something so the what part is solved by
our great automatic speech recognition
we have our own speech recognition built
in-house it's pretty cool it's better
than what you get if you just go to one
of those api's and it's trained in
domain and the who part is what we're
going to do today so speaker
identification why can't we have nice
things why can't we know who's speaking
from the systems so first of all usually
we use Eve which is a recording agent
our software joins your calls and
records it some of the calls come to us
from other recording agents and they
tend to record mono channels as well why
this is again historically the way that
phone systems work they really like mono
and it kind of moved into the world of
phones over IP as well another reason
that we want this we may have multiple
people speaking in the same room so they
sit next to the speaker and there might
be two or three of them and it might
even be the one of the representatives
is physically at the customers place and
some of the others are
remote so we don't know who the people
are in each room and we want to identify
everybody and also easily browse between
the speakers finally when we get there
we're going to do the same room
recording in order to provider of this
wonderful technology for field sales
people are not just remote ones so let's
get into the technology what speech I'm
talking right now and this is type of
speech it's a time varying signal with
multiple layers of information so this
sounds really cool I'm saying some words
I'm providing emotion hopefully I'm not
all flat you can listen to my voice and
find some properties about me maybe my
height my weight my gender also you can
find some discourse and entrainment cues
this means if I stop talking and I say
does anybody know what entrainment is
you see so some of you mark that you
don't know it means that I'm giving you
cue for what I'm expecting you to do I
gave you a cue that I'm expecting an
answer so all of these all of them come
together inside the speech and this
information in is conveyed in some sort
of frequency over time that my vocal
chords are producing so what's an
end-to-end speaker separation we're
going to present our method for
identifying the speakers and word
differs from what you'd see if you'd
search online for the realization of
verification is that I care about
getting the first picture that we had in
the beginning where you can see where
everybody spoke I don't care just about
the speaker separation or just about the
deep learning part that we we have
somewhere around here or just about the
clustering I want to put this all
together into one working system so
we're starting with the voice activity
detection luckily enough this is pretty
much solved problem we want to identify
when people are speaking we start with
separating silence from noise which
could be any kind of speech or trains
going in the background
dog barking while you're connecting to
your WebEx room and after we did that we
want to identify the difference between
speech and non speech incidents for this
we use the GMM approach to the classic I
like to do that I think it's been
working I see here 2013 so this is
nothing very recent and we fit two GM's
one of them - the noise example another
- the speech example and then we just do
a Bayesian likelihood and decide for
each frame whether this is speech or
noise if you want to build this at your
house it's good to train on your own
noises mark a bunch of places where your
recordings have noises it could be
different noises in our case some people
like to have meetings in cafes so
background chatter is something that you
want to eliminate so you add this to the
training data you can do this in Cal D
which is the open source speech
processing environment that we use
pretty simple next thing we want to
extract some features so I'm not going
to dive too much into that MFC seas are
the the standard classic way of turning
speech into features they correlate to
the way that we separate sound in our
ear so these are again 60 70s technology
I think there are a bunch of ranges of
audio and each of them is simple for the
decibel over these short periods of 40
milliseconds so now we're going to get
into the interesting parts so we have
these small frames windows of voice
frames each of them is 40 milliseconds
long and we have the EM FCC's which are
just a vector of numbers for each of the
frequencies what were the decibels and
what we're going to do is a bottom-up
approach up to a third and point were
we're going to try and identify inside
the call which overlapping windows are
the same person speaking so this is
going to give us these small ranges
one-second ranges or two second ranges
where we're pretty sure it's the same
speaker the approach is again a Gaussian
approach because this is not an
extremely hard problem when somebody
speaks for a second it's pretty
consecutive and it sounds very similar
and we can fit a Gaussian to the wheel
to the window doesn't have to be a GMM
like before it's just a simple Gaussian
and using the information in it we can
decide for each of these tiny frames of
40 milliseconds are they're the same
speaker or not based on the KL
divergence between them so again this is
pretty simple mathematically if you go
to the reviews from 8 years ago this is
the the prime technology used back then
so we use it to create these one-second
segments where we are pretty certain
that this is the the same person
speaking the next step this is the step
I'm going to delve into is called the
eye vector embedding we want to identify
that a certain second belongs to speaker
and we want to do it by representing it
in a lower dimension now this is in
Hebrew but this is a piece from
Franzen's book called the corrections it
came out in 1999 and one of the
characters which things and very bendy
for him in the book has made twenty
million dollars from building this
program called idæan melody by embedding
music into a low vector space and then
allowing people to search it so
basically fronting is describing Shazam
in 1999 with the right math and
everything so the math has been around
and this guy knows how to do research
seriously it's it's good stuff and what
I'm going to describe now is how to
extract these
which I'm not sure was completely right
about in 1999 so where do I vectors
begin we go back to 2011
the original approach is based on steel
GM M's deep learning is only picking up
at this point and GM's rule the earth at
least the speech industry and what we
want to do is take these 1 second length
windows that we are pretty sure are the
same person and we want to represent
them in a small space so we have all of
these tiny 40 millisecond second frames
and we want to combine them into one
vector so we can easily say that this is
the same speaker when and compare them
to one another so the idea here is to
train something called a universal
background model a model that says how
do people sound like where each of the
speakers is drawn from this model with
just their parameter so each person is
just a parameter version of the
universal model of speech and at the end
it's going to compare people using some
kind of Bayesian score or learn some
kind of cosine distance using SVM so
this is really by the way if you open
the paper it's super complicated they're
using things like front-end features and
and UBM and and I vector extractors and
none of it is very well explained in the
document now this is lucky for us
because you can replace all of that
stuff with deep learning so we have
training data we have these audio
segments that we have the speaker marked
so we say this is speaker 1 this is
speaker - this is speaker 3 and we're
going to learn the framework of the
network is simply an embedding layer
followed by a DNN followed by softmax
layer that points to all of these
speakers so
we have in the training data 1,000 or
2,000 speakers and we want to simply
train the network to say that each of
these segments is the right speaker
we're going to train this by predicting
known speakers and we're going to
propagate the loss from this point back
to the embedding faction by seeing when
it gets it right and when it gets it
wrong finally we're going to drop the
DNN and the softmax and everything that
we learned and now we've got this really
great embedding function that can work
in the wild he doesn't have to be those
same two thousand people because we
assume that it learned if you make the
embedding small enough it's going to
learn about what people sound like now
does anybody know what the problem here
with the softmax layer and predicting
everyone could be so it's it's got to do
some overfitting but mostly we are
predicting a huge space of two thousand
people and the softmax layer it's soft
matte layer get really large so it's not
very a good way to learn things more
than 2,000 no yeah because it won't
scale for the learning you can't predict
mm you predict 2000 levels you're
already taxing the the learning system
you have to go to Iraqi Cal softmax and
start doing all these weird things
people doing the word embeddings but it
doesn't scale very well it doesn't learn
very well if you make it big so you
can't even if you have a hundred
thousand speakers like Baidu in the
paper I'm going to show in a second it
just won't work with that kind of
network so what are we going to do
instead of predicting 2,000 speakers
we're going to predict one label for
each learning instance we're going to
take two audio segments and there is are
going to be from the same speaker or
from two different speakers now we're
going to embed each of them using the
same network and then predict who the
weather this is the same speaker or not
so we turn the problem from a problem
where we are using a soft max layer to
predict some 2000 labels
instead we are going to predict every
time zero one is it the same person or
not the same person so these are Siamese
the network that proach was invented by
a unicorn at the same year of the I
vectors people try to do that in in
speech but without the old a vector
theory behind it and in 2017 very
similar model was shown in academia by
Schneider and Povey so we have the
Siamese network but what's the problem
here most people don't sound exactly the
same and also we are learning a
classification problem when what we want
to learn at the end of the day is a
similarity problem we want to know when
examples or samples are similar and have
a distance function so instead of
learning a classification problem Li at
all from Baidu are suggesting to use
triplets we have the anchor which is the
real person we have two samples one of
them is that person or one of them is a
confounder and what we force the model
to learn is the right cosine distance so
the cosine distance learned it punishes
it when the anchor is too far from the
positive example and too close to the
negative example the the good thing here
we are going to learn a cosine
similarity so we don't need anything
afterwards we've already learned
something which is the similarity the
embedding function now very easily can
be used to compare new samples which are
you know out of the main our sample
whatever this allows Baidu to learn how
to compare I think about I'm it's arena
here but they are using some hundred and
twenty thousand people
I'm sure only for good purposes same
thing from Google so this came from
the recession community but in the
verification community in Google they're
doing the same thing but they're adding
this little tiny thing instead of just
picking two samples one of them that
person and the other one is random
we each time we take the speaker which
sounds the most like that person so it
would have to learn to distinguish very
similar voices and all just have an easy
task and not learn enough so they can
instead of randomly picking their
confusion samples it samples it from the
most similar speaker and this is very
similar to face not in vision and the
approach itself is very similar to other
triplet similarity approaches that you
see in the literature okay so we know
about a vector embedding and how to do
it with the deep learning but how do we
assemble our system from that so the
next step is clustering we have these
short segments we've embedded them into
a really cool vector that separates them
running space and now we want to create
a cluster per speaker on the call you
can do this with agglomerated clustering
you can do this with k-means it works
pretty much the same and one of the
problems here is once you have a few
segments clustered how do we score the
distances when do we stop we don't
actually know how many people there are
on the call and some of this is just you
know data munging
switch to a smarter distance metrics
such as PL da or you can learn the
cut-offs in your in domain data so when
should you still combine two neighbors
in neighbor-joining in the memory of
clustering and when should you stop so
we have the clusters and now we
basically solve the dilation problems we
have a bunch of speakers now we want to
label them with names so how do we do
that given an audio sample we're going
to match it to known speakers we
automatically learn the voices of
recurrent users I mean the users are
paying us they are making multiple calls
they are on most of these calls which
they play so it's very easily to find
the right person within all of those
goals and automatically identify their
voice in a later call
using the cosine distance which we
learned with the verification problem we
can also argument the speaker with name
if this is a video conference you type
in your name or your email we can see
you are you can further if some people
are not no you can use text
classification on the automatic speech
recognition that Texas we got from The
Voice in order to decide whether this is
the representative or the prospect so we
combine all of these things together in
this big soup until we get this result
so we here we have five people two of
them are sitting in the same room two
others are calling in on different
machines and we can still separate them
all and guess their names worst case we
say this is the speaker or if we use the
Texas if occation we can say this is one
of the representatives but we are not
sure what her name is so the result we
can see who spoke when how long for and
how much of the total time of the call
did they dominate this provides useful
information for the customer in order
for to do training search see what the
customer said and not the rep and
everything that I mentioned before thank
you
just on time right just to mention
before we go to questions we have
another meetup on the 8th where we are
hosting the CE CTO of tracks
it's going to be really cool we'd love
to see you there
[Applause]
person in the last row so as I said we
learned the result of when should we
combine a cluster with another cluster
you cluster it and you get these small
clusters that you are 100% sure of the
similarities guy related rocketing and
then you have some point to decide am I
going to mix these two or not and this
is you just learn it empirically from
the data yes we're going to assign it to
one side or the other
yes yeah I actually spoke about
identifying while moments here about a
year ago so this is actually intrument
which I mentioned before finding out
what other cues there are in the
conversation you can see it from the
frequency changes when you go up and
down a lot in the frequency this means
that you are very engaged or angry
depends on your culture and your the way
that you speak but in general engage is
better than the board yes through this
process they found any challenges with
accents
and front flip it to the wall forward
for for the text analysis oh yeah of
course it works better for the majority
of what you have in your training data
but what we do is we keep transcribing
more calls and adding them to training
data and retraining so hopefully we do
pretty well on almost you know common
accents in the US but yeah we have these
great customers in Texas and they I love
listening to their calls but the court
he probably goes down a smidgen yes
where someone's have a speaker going
yeah yeah I mean if we go back to the
example here we can see same speaker
same speaker then it's mark speaking
then it moves to Kelsey then Joe again
then Preston then Joe again then grace
ray speaks for it'll be then Joe go oh
you speak because of the microphones
yeah it can cause errors depends that it
really depends when you're when your
sound quality is good you're going to
get like SR the this text is going to be
without any mistakes and this is going
to be spot-on
if you have really loved noise going on
it means that the whole thing might not
work yeah that happens
but it's it's pretty rare it depends how
bad it is it and how similar are the
voices if you have two people with very
similar voices who also have a crazy
echo going on it
yeah we may fail but it works in in 97%
of their cases less question
hiren sometimes the eye depends depends
how closely the human is listening when
you try to annotate this it's pretty
hard in the beginning but if you listen
to the whole call it's pretty easy so it
depends how much effort you put into
that that's it thank you yeah you can
get me outside
[Applause]